o futuro é o próximo segundo eu pensei
no auge da clareza que amanhã eu poderia
não mais existir
era uma vez uma garota que diferente
alice aquela do país das maravilhas
ela sabe exatamente para o dia cada
passo seu era pensado e calculado seus
objetivos ambiciosos eram
milimetricamente planejados
essa pessoa controladora e cheio de
certezas era eu renata cinco anos atrás
até que um dia aconteceu atrás na minha
vida
trap oi pois é com o nome esquisito
destino deve ser coisa boa
atrás ela é uma síndrome genética rara
que tem um alto poder incapacitante
então o meu corpo entra num processo
constante limpando influindo formação
então é do nos músculos ossos e
articulações febre em problemas na pele
intestino estômago entre outros sintomas
que nem vale a pena eu comentar aqui e
então minha vida ela se transformou mais
novela mexicana com muito drama lágrimas
e suor escorregando então diagnóstico
conclusivo sobre escorregando exames que
não dá em nada sou escorregando troca de
médico show escorregando cabelos caindo
no chuveiro e eu quase fiquei careca
senhor escorregando totalmente diferente
daqueles desenhos inspiradores da pizza
em uma jornada médica de três anos
muitas vezes eu vi a minha vida
escorrendo pela palma da minha vida das
minhas mãos e cada perspectiva de
diagnóstico aumentava a complexidade das
doenças e diminuir a minha qualidade de
vida ea minha expectativa de vida
então agora imagina só sua vida toda
organizada e de repente pernas pro ar
eu não tinha mais controle sobre a minha
vida muito menos sobre o meu corpo
tudo que era sólido e certo se dissolveu
e foi nesse momento que eu perdi a minha
visão de futuro eu não conseguia ver
além eu entrei num círculo vicioso de
incertezas
e apesar de todo o apoio familiar e
amigos e pessoas conhecidas e aí vem o
coração em especial pra minha mãe
em vários momentos eu perdi a esperança
e até a fé que aquilo tudo fosse
resolver e eu passei pelas cinco fases
do outro a raiva ameaçam a barganha a
depressão e aceitação e assim eu tô
nessa aqui ainda melhor porque é sempre
de muita terapia
então como dizia jean paul sartre tudo
foi calculado
exceto conviver sem que eu sou a pessoa
que eu tenho uma personalidade muito
forte então eu me recusava a transformar
isso como um definidor da minha vida
então ela me lançou um desafio e como
dizia meu pai eu sou um burro brabo
e foi com essa braveza toques de humor e
muita acidez que eu vi leva dessa
jornada
para quem não entendeu a vibe essa sou
eu as minhas milhares de vôos para são
paulo tentando fazer um pólo de ensino o
placar chegar à sadia
então assim a gente até pode sofrer é
mais um bar de piada eu vou falar um
pouco pra vocês agora sobre como as
pessoas elas não sabem lidar com outras
pessoas doentes está é durante quatro
dos cinco anos que eu falei pra vocês é
onde muleta
às vezes com a muleta às vezes com duas
e assim as pessoas elas são muito
discretas e toda vez que entrava no
elevador ou em outros ambientes também
mas no lavadora batata sempre viu me
perguntando que foi na sua perna e eu
descobrir com o tempo que se eu falasse
a verdade às pessoas elas tenham
resposta padrão pra mim
elas diziam é elas diziam que tinha um
médico que a resolver o meu problema que
é descobrir o diagnóstico ela tem um
medicamento um tratamento milagroso
ou ela conhecia uma pessoa o mesma coisa
que eu mesmo não sendo raro há também
gente e ainda e essas eu realmente
gostaria de matar no potinho você tem fé
suficiente para segurar
então a partir daí eu comecei a me cair
e as pessoas perguntavam para mim que
foi isso que aconteceu com a sua perna e
eu senti foi atropelado por um caminhão
e essa visão saber que era o caminhão
chamado trapos né
e aí eu vou abrir um parêntese realmente
para agradecer a todos os profissionais
que no último ano me tiraram das muletas
incluindo meu marido porque nunca setor
[Aplausos]
e também dá alguns conselhos para vocês
sobre como tratar uma pessoa que tem
plano de saúde
a primeira coisa é seja discreto doença
é uma coisa muito íntima
tá a segunda coisa nada de olhares de
pena a pessoa já tem problemas demais
para lhe dá pra ter que lidar com sua
pena e por fim quer realmente fazer
diferença
pergunta uma pessoa está não que ela tem
e se faça presente e disponível mas
voltando para o assunto
como você já deve ter pedido o meu corpo
estava uma bagunça mas a minha mente não
quer dizer que no momento que eu ficava
chapada de remédios
alguém que já tomou remédio pra dor
alguém remédio forte pra dor tramadol
codeína pregabalina pronto imagina isso
tudo junto e misturado
minha gente a minha vida ela ficava
lento até completar as frases ficava
difícil eu acho que eu nunca tive tantos
momentos de contemplação na minha vida
mas tirando isso nos momentos mais
calmos e também nos longos períodos de
cama eu comecei a fazer coisas que
muitas vezes eu queria não tinha tempo
então eu comecei a ler a estudar a
desenhar desenvolver bijuterias a entre
outras coisas que precisava colocar toda
aquela energia em algum canto porque eu
não conseguia mais trabalhar
eu não conseguia praticar atividade
física que era uma coisa que despertava
minha mente e também não tenho mais vida
social porque saí com dou é muito
difícil e parece que todas as cadeiras
de bares e restaurantes de maceió são
desconfortáveis ficar detido até que um
dia no meio desse caos todo e assim
imaginar dois amigos com certeza não
bateu muito bem na cabeça eles me
propuseram sociedade
cada um tem as suas próprias atividades
áries é mais é essa empresa era uma
coisa aspiracional um plano para o
futuro ea minha função seria pensar em
soluções que poderiam ser ilegais no
mercado
como vocês podem imaginar eu aceitei
eu precisava colocar toda aquela energia
ósseo e pressão e as pessoas que me
conhecem sabem quanto foi difícil pra
mim porque eu sou a pessoa muito
inquieta então a limitação foi terrível
e foi aqui aconteceu empreendedorismo na
minha vida mas o fato que mudou tudo e
girar a chave foi quando eu fiz um curso
de kurran team que é ocorra até ele é
conseqüente para a moda está ocorrendo é
ele é um profissional que ele capta a
mudança de comportamento e aí ele tenta
descobrir como vai ser essa a próxima
grande novidade ou seja a pessoa estuda
comportamentos para e vão impactar o
mercado e o mundo é meio que um estudo
do futuro
e aí depois desse desse curso no meus
momentos de contemplação é eu percebi
que as técnicas aplicadas naquele tipo
de pesquisa ele poderia também ser
aplicado para outros negócios e outros
tipos de negócios geral e então eu
fiquei com essa ideia martelando na
minha cabeça e foi aí que eu decidi que
eu queria estudar o futuro para poder
fazer o presente melhor sabe a gente
vive meio que desconectado da nossa
questão da própria mortalidade
ninguém fica pensando o tempo todo eu
posso morrer amanhã eu posso morrer
agora você pode morrer agora mas a gente
vive no automático e se é uma coisa
maravilhosa essa arrogância ou falta de
consciência humana é nosso instinto de
defesa
se a gente ficasse pensando o tempo todo
que ia morrer
a ge surtava agora imagina vocês no dia
que eu tive essa clareza mental que
amanhã eu poderia não mais existir ea
doença faz essas coisas com gente ela tá
esse choque
a primeira coisa que eu fiz foi raspar
minha previdência privada
casar e viajar de muleta e com 13
boletins pulmonares para o deserto do
atacama no chile há mais de 3 mil metros
acima do nível do mar e fiquei sem igual
agora tá então é mas tirando isso assim
a questão pessoal e viciante que se
tornou estudar tendências estudar o
futuro é porque eu comecei como eu
comecei a ver o futuro do qual eu não
sabia se eu faria parte por mais
estranho que seja eu tenho a sensação de
conforto que nesse abraço aqui então eu
ficava animada de ver pedacinhos do
futuro que eu não sei se existiria pra
mim depois daquele curso eu comecei a
ver todas as transformações que estava
acontecendo no mundo e fica observando
os sinais de comportamento que mudava e
cruzar informações era um verdadeiro
universo paralelo na minha cabeça bem
back milan mas cada vez que eu aprendi
há algo novo eu tinha plena consciência
que a nossa realidade ela está mudando
profundamente e aceleradamente
minha gente o mundo tá muito doido
coisas que funcionavam durante vários
anos
hoje simplesmente não funciona mais ea
sensação que eu tenho é que eu tenho é
que as pessoas elas estão desligadas ou
estão desnorteados
ou seja com 53 são despreparados para o
futuro
e aí foi que eu percebi que alguém
precisava ajudá las desse processo de
despertar então olhar para o futuro e se
preparar para o futuro se tornou questão
de sobrevivência como assim renata
sobrevivência
com essa mudança acelerada que a gente
está passando se abre um cenário tanto
criativo e cheio de oportunidades como
do outro lado tem um cenário
apocalíptico quase destruição a gente vê
setores segmentos sendo engolidos ou
dizimados e acontece
lembra que a empresa lá que eu falei
naquela empresa ela junto comigo ela
evoluiu ela se reconfigurou e se
transformou na mescla que é exatamente
isso uma mistura de pessoas
de várias áreas diferentes que se
propuseram a mudar realidades a partir
do futuro baseado em pesquisa e
desenvolvimento de negócios
a nossa missão é linda ir além do agora
e foi nesse ambiente seguro e livre que
eu tive dentro das minhas milhares
limitações criar testar e inovar e foi
lá no méxico que no mesmo momentos é e
comecei a me aprofundar no estudo do
futuro e eu criei um método de pesquisa
de tendências em foco principal desse
método era que ele se adequasse à nossa
realidade e preparar as pessoas para o
futuro e você vai dizer renata desculpa
mas pesquisa tendência não é algo novo
o que é que tem inovado nisso e eu vou
perguntar pra vocês quantas pessoas têm
acesso a ela
quando você vê no mercado de empresas
que trabalham com pesquisas e tendências
os clientes dela são grandiosas é disney
puma red bull o volvo
então as pessoas elas não têm acesso a
essa informação e conta que eu percebi
na minha jornada é que o acesso à
informação qualificada e conhecimento
ele muda realidades
o acesso ao futuro ele muda realidades e
o acesso é a sobrevivência
então como dizia o william gibson que é
um escritor e visionário o futuro eles
ataque
ele só não foi igualmente distribuído
hoje na mescla a gente tem uma solução
acessível para pequenas e médias
empresas que são mais de 90% das
empresas que giram nossa economia
então a partir da pesquisa de tendências
ela tem acesso ao futuro e é
interessante como a gente percebe que
isso causa impacto
a empresa ela vê o futuro ela sabe que
pode ser diferente
muitas vezes difícil ela vai ter que se
adaptar mas é a partir dali ela sabe ela
sabe o caminho para onde ela vai
então é interessante quando a empresa
ela se atualiza internaliza aquela
mudança ela impacta todo o ambiente e é
um impacto
6 engraçado que determinado momento
estudar tendências e estudar o futuro
mudou é tão para lançado como história
pessoal que fica difícil dissociar uma
coisa da outra e eu aprendi a hashtag
unificar a minha própria vida mudar a
realidade e mudar a realidade das outras
pessoas
então pessoas tendo seu nome de um
propósito e é interessante porque não é
só ligada a negócios é ligado à história
pessoal também quando ainda não tinha o
diagnóstico é e meu meu corpo estava com
altos picos de inflamação eu fiz alguns
tratamentos experimentais
um deles foi a plasmaférese basicamente
internada no hospital
colocar um cateter e o meu sonho era
filtrado na maquininha o tratamento em
si ele trazer benefícios pra mim mas eu
ia contrariada me internar colocar um
cateter que era um sofrimento
até que um dia pesquisando tendências e
descobri que era uma tendência de bem
estar às pessoas sozinhas pra ficar
jovens
tá então uma coisa que era o sofrimento
pra mim e fez ficar gata
ou seja essa pele que de 25 anos no
corpo de 33 foi o resultado de mais de
30 sessões de plasma férias e está
assente numa dessas brincadeiras
eu também tive acesso a terapias
integrativas que ajudaram na cola da
dívida
eu também tive acesso a acompanhar a
primeira vez que fizeram a reprogramação
genética uma pessoa com doença auto
imune
então isso ainda está em estudo então o
futuro me dá esperança
eu ainda não me curei eu estou
aguardando a medicação há dois anos na
justiça
em alguns distritos no final porque
demora tanto que ainda não realizei não
virei digital influência é quem sabe
depois o tex e vou ter mais de 600
seguidores instagram ea mescla ela ainda
está caminhando pra ganhar o mundo
mas uma coisa que eu tenho certeza hoje
além de ser uma pessoa rara e cara é que
a pesquisa de tendência ela devolveu uma
coisa que eu tinha perdido lá atrás que
a minha visão de futuro
então é o futuro ele está ali é você
fazer parte dele então aproveite seu
próximo segundo pra construir acessar
esse futuro eu finalizo com a sabedoria
do passado que me inspirou muito
tratamento jornada
[Música]
obrigada
[Aplausos]